pousse-t-on barons du tout et d'abord
bouya
je sais que humainement tu sais que moi
si tu étais l'un d'eux tu aurais pas
attendu pour me liquider
à 1h07 le satellite odyssey a enregistré
les images d'un objet inconnu passant
devant mars il s'est arrêté à 400 km
au-dessus de la terre et est
actuellement en orbite autour de notre
planète nous les avons appelés les
autres
qu'est ce qu'ils veulent la terre c'est
pour ça qu'ils sont laquées si ils ont
besoin de la terre
d'abord ils nous ont coupé l'électricité
précipitant le monde dans le chaos
ensuite ils nous ont enlevé une ville en
dévastant tout
après ils nous ont enlevé la vie avec un
virus aéroportée inguérissable
pire que tout ils nous ont enlevé le
contrôle les autres étaient déjà parmi
nous à exterminer tous les survivants
les autres se préparent pour la
cinquième vague
ils sont capables de se loger dans des
êtres humains et de commander leurs
actions ils sont semblables à nous on
fait quoi maintenant on revient sur
l'autre on ne peut plus faire confiance
à personne
comment peut-on combattre les autres si
on ne sait pas les reconnaître
tu étais pas prêt pour la fin du mondial
je dois aller chercher mon frère
je vais te conduire
tu ne sais absolument rien de lui
les autres onemi savent et je vais aller
si nous subissons des attaques
simultanées sur les dernières
générations
un cinquième bague réussi l'humanité
sera rennais de la surface du globe
les autres considèrent notre espoir
comme une faiblesse ils ont tort
la terre est à nous
nous n'en serons pas m